this presentation is delivered by the
Stan
development
yeah I could evening I'm my gym plumber
the Dean of the School of Engineering
I'm we're delighted to have all of you
here tonight in addition to a packed
auditorium here on campus there are
literally hundreds of alums and friends
watching over the internet live tonight
for this for this really very special
event we're here tonight as all of you
know to recognize and honor professor
emeritus Don Knuth for being one of the
original eight heroes of the Stanford
engineering school the the Stanford
engineering heroes program recognizes
the achievements of Stanford engineers
who have in many ways profoundly changed
to the course of human social and
economic progress through engineering
the heroes our heroes embody all of the
really that the School of Engineering
stands for innovation entrepreneurship
leadership and obviously world-class
teaching and research and we're just
delighted that Dunn is one of the eight
inaugural Stanford engineering heroes he
joins quite an illustrious group of
others in this same inaugural class of
heroes Fred Terman
William Hewlett Dave Packard Charles
Litton William Durant ray dolby and bent
Cerf and so it's quite an illustrious
group of people affiliated with Stanford
engineering so unlike many award events
all that we ask of people who are being
recognized as Stanford engineering
heroes is for them to tell us how they'd
like to spend the day on campus and so
what's occurring here at night is really
Dawn's suggestion he spent some really
wonderful times earlier today with some
of our students in computer science and
other parts of the university and had a
night we had a nice dinner with some of
these students and and he asked tonight
that we just have this event where he
could answer questions and so that's
really the format of the of the evening
now dawn even though the title of this
session is all questions answered on
wanted me to make certain that you
realize that if you ask questions
outside the field of computer
programming
that he claims not to be a particular
expert in some of these areas and his
answers actually may carry somewhat less
authority in some of these other areas
than a Wikipedia article article for
example so the format for the evenings
I'm gonna say a few words of
introduction about dawn and then he will
get up and make a few comments and
remarks and then we're delighted that
Professor Dan Bonet of our CS department
is here and Dawn Dan will actually
moderate the Q&A session we have a set
up here so that people who are watching
over the anok and ask questions and Dan
I'll say a bit about that in just a
second but there'll be plenty of
opportunity for those of you here in the
audience to ask questions if it's
convenient try and get to the
microphones or we'll bring them to you
if you're in the middle of the room so
we can capture the questions as well so
I don't really think I need to say very
much about dawn
all of you are here tonight because you
know him and and have tremendous respect
for him
he's clearly one of the world's most
influential computer scientists he laid
the foundations for modern compilers and
has widely recognized as the father of
algorithm analysis he's also the author
as all of you know of the landmark
series the art of computer programming
which is considered by many people to be
one of the most important scientific
writings of the past century Don will be
doing a book signing at the end of the
formal session as well for those of you
that would like to have him assign a
book it was actually during that time
when Don was beginning to write these
these books that he became very
frustrated with sort of the capability
of electronic publishing tools and so of
course taking matters into his own hands
he wrote his own code or language for
programming for text setting which of
course quickly became the gold standard
force for mathematical and scientific
publications it's interesting I learned
a few things about Don's earlier life as
as preparing for this event he actually
demonstrated his computational prowess
was the earliest record we could find it
but I guess there may have been some
earlier in eighth grade when he won a
national contest to form as many words
as possible
the phrase Ziegler's giant bar so you
take those three words and then the
contest was to make as many words as you
can out of the letters that are in those
those three words
so probably the judges had in mind that
the winner would might generate
something on the order of a couple of
thousand words out of those letter
combinations done found 4,500 and won
the won the competition he went to
college what is now Case Western Reserve
University for his undergraduate work
and he initially actually planned to
study music in college he's quite as men
I'm sure all of you know he's quite an
accomplished musician and plays the
organ the tube with saxophone and I
think several other instruments as well
and the story goes that one day he was
on his way to band practice and he
missed the bus and so waiting for the
next bus to arrive he actually unraveled
an extra-credit math problem that was so
difficult in the math class that the
professor teaching the class that said
that if anybody could solve it they'd
get a nought to make a in the class and
so he solved it was waiting for the next
bus and that turned into him becoming a
math major with the highest GPA of any
of the math majors in his class in 1963
Don earned his PhD degree from Caltech
in mathematics and not long after that
he joined the computer science faculty
here at Stanford he taught here
unbelievably successfully for many years
and then decided he wanted to devote
full time to working on his books and so
he retired from the University and he
now spends as you know his full-time
writing writing his books but he we
still say my camp was riding his bike
around and he still gives lectures on
campus and this is still a great friend
of all of us in engineering and in
computer science
he's obviously received virtually every
award that's given in the field of
computer science including the Turing
award the National Medal of Science
membership in the National Academy of
Sciences and so on so tonight we're just
delighted to be able to honor him and to
recognize him and Don we have for you it
was a slight token of our appreciation
this is a replica of the plaque that
sits on the honors wall just outside
that the it's named for engineering
heroes wallets it's just outside the
thorium here so please join me in
welcoming Don Knuth
[Applause]
okay well it's working yeah okay well
I'm I'm I guess I have to start off by
saying I'm uncomfortable as a hero
I I walked by the quarters of the
computer science department past 1:00
heroes door after another and but anyway
I'm quite happy to be here as a
representative a heroic Department the
other thing is about these questions a
lot of you in the audience I know I've
been in my classes and I had this
tradition that the last day of quarter
you didn't have to come to class if you
didn't want to but if you did come I
would answer any questions that you had
this was so love you know people pay
their tuition and they they get through
a whole quarter and they haven't still
got the answer to the question they want
so so I always reserved the last day of
class for that it's an idea that I got
from Richard Feynman at Caltech before
coming here and and I kept it up every
year so here I am back again now ready
to answer any any question on any
subject and maybe Danny wants to say how
the how it's going to interact with the
web sure sure I'll say a few words so
I'm honored to be to be moderating this
event my name is Dan Bona I'm a
professor here so let's see I'm just in
charge of the mechanics so a toot there
are two microphones in the aisles so
anyone who wants to ask a question we
just ask that you please walk up to the
microphone and ask the question there so
everyone can hear you especially the
folks on the web can hear can hear the
questions we're also using Google
moderator today so anyone on the web can
submit a question through Google
moderator obviously I'll be sitting here
from time to time I'll interrupt the
flow of questions that are coming for
the audience and I'll just read
questions from the web I also want to
mention that Google moderator is kind of
an impressive software and that folks
who folks can vote on other people's
questions so if you have an iPhone or an
Android phone and you want to vote on
people's questions
please go ahead and do that similarly
here on the webpage and go ahead our
votes and actually I guess I just wanted
to say one sentence I guess when I was a
story that I'm sure many many of you
have the similar experience when I was
growing up I just happened to run into
some one of our bookshelves I ran it
happen to run into volume 2 of the art
of computer programming volume 2 is on
semi numerical algorithms and I read it
and I fell in love with computing on
numbers and primes and as a results I
don't think I ever told you this dawn it
is because of that book that I ended up
doing cryptography and that is what's my
main area of research these days if I'd
run into volume 1 or volume 3 my life
could have been completely different
Wow no no not because because now you've
been doing so much that means I have to
write volume 2 squared yes indeed well
since I'm the moderator I guess I get to
ask the very first question and then I'm
gonna hand it to everybody to to follow
on so the question is I'm curious about
is probably no the mathematicians always
have have always had like a natural key
open problem that they can present to
the public that's a very simple open
problem that it's easy very easy for
folks to understand and they could get
people to kind of think about deep
questions I guess it used to be from a
spa steering now unfortunately that's no
longer an open question so I guess the
leading question these days is say the
Riemann hypothesis may be not as easy to
understand so still fairly easy the
states so my question to you is if you
wanted to get someone excited about
algorithms what would you use is the
kind of the nice beautiful open problem
to present Wow okay so you want a
problem that a that a young person would
understand not a problem that
necessarily a US congressman would
understand yes smart young person
okay well lots of copies of my book out
in the corridor and and it's full of
research problems I'm so person to maybe
like of course the most famous open
problem in theoretical computer science
is about P versus NP and it's still not
that easy to understand to explain to a
to young person so still it's a little
bit like asking up asking a parent which
of their children is their favorite so
the there are several several things
okay well let me let me give you one and
see if I can get it right so I have the
book there if somebody has a copy of I'm
for a I could I could turn to the page
and just put it on screen okay okay so
okay well anyway there's lotsa research
problems in here but but there's one
that that I think you know might might
be fun to work on and and leave
somewhere I have no idea how how how
easy it's going to be or anything if I
can if I can remember what it was look
where it is here but it's essentially it
arises to say if can you get all let me
see mmm boy this just might take me to
this might take me too long
I should use my computer to do a search
for the em1
ok lick so that dialect let me pass on
that and give you an give you one of the
first ones that I found here it's a so
we have so suppose you want to find all
all ways of mixing say three three
zeroes with three ones and so and and so
in this particular case whether I think
there are twenty ways to do it and and
the idea is that every step you have to
get to another one by by swapping the
first one with some others it's like it
I could swap the zero and the one and I
could go one zero zero zero one one for
example okay and then now I can swap
that with with some other zero so I can
go to zero 1 zero zero 1 1 and so on but
I'm supposed to get everyone exactly
once and it can generate those oh now
it's a simple problem like you can
explain to kids but it has a lot of
corollaries and maybe even encrypt in
cryptography because it was it was
invented by a guy named Wiedemann who
you probably know at NSA so so there in
fact there are lots of simple problems
like that that that remain open and and
no reason why a young person couldn't
couldn't solve it with a new idea okay
thanks and in the 1790s the French tried
to introduce a metric time system yeah
and yesterday I was reading the article
about leap seconds and the
communications of the ACM so we have
leap seconds sometimes it's in June and
December because the earth is not
rotating exactly you know 24 hours so
how would a computer scientists design a
I'm system taking into account the fact
that humans live here on this earth
taking into account what the fact that
we're humans living here on earth okay
so yeah I guess that's a fact so so so
if we go back to my and you go back to
the flashing computer screen this is the
the things that we've had we've had
flashing on the screen here are you know
it takes a while but anyway these are
these are sort of random pages from from
the other book that's in the corridor
the book on called papers and fun and
games and and and one of the topics in
that book it gives my first technical
paper which I published while I sent it
in when I was still in high school and
it was published in Mad Magazine and and
in fact I had they it was a system of
weights and measures themselves your
problem Jeff because it says don't worry
about the fact that the year isn't it
isn't an even number of days or anything
like that let's just let's just make the
whole system decimal and so forget about
having 365.2422 nine so on days new year
let's have one hundred it has lots of
advantages as you know you have
birthdays more often and the the the
conversion from instead of having light
years you have light kosnovski x' but
the conversion is exactly the same as
the speed of light so so a lot of things
become simpler in a decimal that's of
course maybe a computer scientist would
have made a binary but I didn't know
about that
okay so yeah I want to run through a lot
of questions so that we cover there's a
very popular question along ago
so what could still be done in the
computer science world that you would
feel would provide the greatest impact
to humanity
what is left to discover build or create
almost everything that is the top
question and look okay very good okay
well you know I would I would call the
top of my list would be would be in the
in the field of medical making making
patients histories visually easy to
understand and to understand epidemics
and all kind of things about about
health and I think there's a tremendous
opportunity there not just to give it
things in terms of pie charts and things
like that but you can animate and and
you can show all kind of different the
eye it seems to me that that the that
there must be good ways to to take all
this data somehow we have to worry about
the privacy and security as you know but
when still of be able to to make much
better ways to visualize that and that
will improve the happiness of patients
and doctors and the health of everybody
I mean that's just when I got my head
hey I'm sorry I don't ask the smartest
of questions but still my question is do
spend much time reading on the Internet
and if you do which sides to read to do
it oh yeah I certainly am addicted to
the internet tonight and I don't know
how I could live without it and and if I
were at home I could just we could just
go through the the history of if you
know my queries to Safari for example
this morning of the probably used it
several dozen times today
you know I translated something from
French and but I also looked up
lots of phrases and words and and so on
so what so i but i but I try not to get
too addicted to things that are
obviously going to gonna consume all my
time like like various games right I
write this book about fun and games in
and I and that's really the story of my
life but also how I highly resistant I'm
not doing only things that were that
were that were exploring in that way
mmm-hmm so quick follow on a question
from the moderator
yeah right so folks are folks want to
know if you contribute to Wikipedia do I
contribute to Wikipedia that's that's
interesting yeah now it's been a few
months I often I don't have an account
at Wikipedia I don't log in but I you
know they always say it's better if you
do that but I but I often find typos am
i you know so I often just correct
comedy stuff like that I can't let that
go by and but but I don't have time to
follow through and see if you if the
things I suggested it actually got done
but but it but often it's well I'll find
that the reference is really screwed up
or or that they really don't know the
history of the subject and so I'll oh oh
I'll call correct the article in and
then in the explanation page with a I'll
I'll give my you know I'll give all my
reasons but the funniest story about the
Wikipedia is that his is I'm trying to
remember exactly but I wish I just had
gotten a a new computer and I was I was
trying to find out if if my energy that
connection was working so I and so you
know I well up comes Google and so I
like I asked for Kluth what else do you
know and so like check this out so and
and at the top it said the Wikipedia
story about Knuth it's always so I the
first time I read whether capito had to
say about me in and well lo and behold I
like going down for few paragraphs and
says he is not a fan of Wikipedia
so so it's like so I corrected it you
know you're not supposed to correct your
hook the article about you about but I
corrected and I said you know he is a
fan of Wikipedia but he has reservations
about something you know about for
example having to keep keep track for a
lifetime of something that you might
have contributed to make sure it doesn't
get screwed up again but anyway I did
that and but I was I was logged in sort
of anonymously through Stanford Network
so but somebody at Wikipedia actually
actually took the trouble to find out
who had made that correction and he sent
he shot back on you know my secretary a
couple days later said I by the way was
that you release the code made this
correction okay so that's my Wikipedia
stuff I'm an undergrad in a computer
science program and I for everyone but
for my classmates at the University of
Waterloo in Canada I find it
increasingly so that not many people
know who you are or what you've done do
you think this is a problem and you know
there are books for sale out there but
that's not my life um you come from
Waterloo today no well it's a great
that's a great school that's the chair
at the School of Computer Science what
yeah okay but anyway no no I I think
it's a tragedy that that young kids
don't know who Martin Gardner was I I
asked that I gave a talk to our grad
students and I asked great people raise
their hand about Martin died about a
year ago today actually and he was he
was certainly a hero of mine and and one
that one of the most certainly the most
successful ever at explaining
mathematics to the not the world
and and and inspiring people to get
going you must have read someone who's
worth - not just some problem - right
okay so so but but no I'm like I'm only
concerned if people forget the ideas
that are in my books rather than not my
name but but the the I I try in the
books to be a spokesperson for for all
of the thousands of people who have
contributed to the field and that's the
and and the thing that bothers me is if
people don't learn anything from the
past and they just think they have to
invent everything from scratch again
because there's so many great ideas out
there and I've spent almost 50 years now
trying to organize some of them and
present them in a way that's useful
further to build on further back to the
internet you don't like to use email so
yeah these days Facebook and Twitter is
in things so do you use that or you talk
yeah so now I understand somebody is
tweeting right now about this lecture so
that that's that's a first
my my my wife is a big fan of Facebook
and and that's one of the things I don't
have time to be addicted to but but
Facebook foot fills a terrific need for
for most people but but not for me I
don't know we need to be in contact with
people I haven't
I have Iowa I have a need to have hours
and hours of you know a free time to
think about stuff that needs a long long
attention span so but don't apologize
for quality of a question that was a
great question but also just if it
occurred to you it probably occurred to
somebody else so don't be afraid to ask
ask a question you know we're not in a
competition for for best question of the
day so let's take a question from the
internet so let's see so the question is
you develop tech at a time when
computers were slow and WYSIWYG word
processing didn't exist if you were to
develop tech today would you make
changes because how computing and
displays has evolved okay so a lot of
you know that I worked on this
typesetting language and and and weed
and that was in the way in way way old
days of the 70s when when it actually
took some time to to typeset right now
we've almost got WYSIWYG anyway because
computers are so fast I just did
Claire's returning like you know when I
get my book but and since it's so fast
there's no reason for me to improve it
anymore as far as I can see because it's
not a bottleneck to doing it like I did
try to write something they may think
for me was was just trying to make
something that would be archival that
that wouldn't be changing every year so
that it would be possible 50 years from
now to take a document from now and
still and-and-and-and-and had to be
updated all the time and so I I actually
worked the other way rather than trying
to keep up with the latest I tried to
have something that could be serve as a
fixed point it amidst all this wonderful
change still have something that that
stays that stays as somehow you can
build
on it because you know it's firm ground
Thank You van as a student back here in
the eighties I actually still think of
marker Jack's as a CS building but
anyway we learned Pascal in the 80s I
moved on I learned C and I learned C++ I
dabbled in Java I've done software
basically for 25 years I still think
it's hard to write any thoughts on how
we can make software development easier
to write faster to write less
error-prone easier to debug especially
with multi-threading coming around yeah
I I have a lot of thoughts about that
and if they're embedded in a book that I
wrote called literate program it's but
even if you use the best technic
techniques that I know it's not gonna be
easy it's gonna be easier it's gonna be
real it's gonna be more reliable then
then anything else any other way I know
but but I don't see it that there's any
Royal Road to software any more than
there's a railroad to mathematic did you
know there's this famous story about
Archimedes and the King said you know
tell me how to make mathematics simpler
like something like that so there's no
silver bullet as far as I know and there
never will be but we can keep trying to
have techniques that are that are better
and my my stick through this programming
idea is write programs with the idea
that you're writing for people to read
them and not and not thinking mostly
that it's a computer going to read them
the and the and so I I've got a web page
about about literate programming that
links to some really good pages about it
and it doesn't well it doesn't uh excuse
me but I'm I got off the subject cuz I
just saw my student Louise sitting there
and I thought of something I want to say
to him
okay so so literate programming uh you
know to me is the greatest thing since
sliced bread but it's something that I
worked on myself so I can do it
unbiased manner still I use it to write
about five programs a weekend and I
can't Prince in the most dramatic
example is the program that I wrote
which was a meta simulator for the MX
computer it was so difficult that I
don't believe I could have written it at
all without that without the ideas of
literate program it would have they
would have had defeated defeated me and
and any anybody I know but with this
tool I could do it so so I'm a big fan
of that of that approach in the main
idea is that I'm writing a program
that's that's a hypertext instead of a
simple text and and I'm addressing it to
another human being possibly myself but
when I'm writing the program I'm in
teacher mode rather than in hacker mode
is there allows or many oh yeah okay
well I better I got a better schedule
the question about the application side
of mathematics and computer science so
do you think it's possible to build a
comprehensive mathematical or computer
model of modern economics where you can
throw in certain variables and get the
prices for a commodity a later on if not
why okay so if I could do that then then
so could everybody else and so everybody
would be equal that's why
so here's a question that's getting a
lot of attention here so the question is
what's your opinion of quantum computers
and if somebody builds a quantum
computer are we basically going to go
back to the drawing board as far as
algorithms are concerned yeah yeah and
what does that mean for the books thanks
ok that's wonderful wonderful question
quantum computers are are very different
from the computers that I'm good at and
and so if someone actually builds it
it's quite conceivable that I wouldn't
have the foggiest idea how to use them
and somebody else should write books
about those and you know it's it's
really interesting the ideas of quantum
computers and multiple worlds you know
all kind of things like that that would
truly revolutionize the things that are
some things that we think are hard would
become easy and that would might just
change the world and everybody who
really wanted to do those things would
would forget about the sequential claim
or the kinds of computers we have now
and that would be good news for me
though because then I could finish my
books much faster because I would still
you know I still like this model and
even though nobody else's would be using
it I would still like because I do this
because it's intellectually satisfying
to solve the problems that I'm doing
when I when I when I use this kind of
computers and I don't care if somebody
spoils it by inventing another kind of
computer I still like this one yes back
when I was a student here like some of
the political aspects of some of the
algorithms like back when I was a
student here RSA had come out and there
was all this controversy about you know
people can now hide their stuff you know
and and then then PGP for a good privacy
and then later they had a Napster but
Napster got shut down until they've met
a bit torrent which was distributed
peer-to-peer and so nobody there's no
middleman and now there's something
called Bitcoin that's come along which
is completely distributed
no middleman digital cryptocurrency so I
just wonder if you've been following any
of these trends and what you have to say
about this
well have you only only comment I would
say is since Marty's standing right
there here we would use diffie-hellman
as the example okay Don so we have Marty
Hellman who's you know I set up the guy
before me your website has frequently
asked questions it also has in
frequently asked questions you have any
idea why those are in frequently asked
questions and why did you feel a need to
ask them okay so yeah Marty's not only
the inventor of many key ideas in
cryptography but also activist for peace
and and many good things and I and that
they were part of my website about in
frequently asked questions I I couldn't
help but but but right when I had spent
some months going around the country
hear what people were talking about and
nobody was talking about what I thought
were the you know important questions of
that work that we're facing our country
and still do and and so I so I I think I
urge you to take a look at these in
frequently asked questions to think
about them because I don't have the
answers to them this is a question to
answer day but these are questions I
don't know how to answer but I but I
also have links on there to the speech
that Richard biesecker gave at one
critical point in Germany's history the
only thing that I'm not a activist and I
I just have these these these feelings
that people ought to be discussing about
the questions and not and I'm disturbed
that that hardly anybody does
unfortunately I don't think my the
points I make on that page are
sufficiently strong because I haven't
got any hate mail could you share with
us a memorable mistake you made in the
lesson you learn from it how much time
do we yes okay so first I could say I
wrote a paper called the errors of tech
which which lists more than a thousand
mistakes that that occurred while I was
while I was writing tech and also has
various ideas about how to learn from
mistakes this is a pervades engineering
there you know civil engineers have to
know what about the bridges that
collapsed and so on and so I but somehow
I don't remember right now any mistake I
ever made
okay so let me think let me see
certainly I I backed the wrong horse
very various times but well I mean the
things like they come to my mind are
more like things to be scolded about
rather than rather than chest I so like
I have to pass on that one that's too
hard I know I think that it's
embarrassing I should be able to think
of I think I should be able to think of
lots of things certainly I know well let
me tell you someone since we were
talking about tech
I based tech on on binary arithmetic
inside but decimal arithmetic outside
from the user so inside of tech
everything is measured in terms of a
scale point and there's 65 536 scaled
points to a point to a printers point
now I could have made that a hundred
thousand instead of a power of two and
and then the when a user says do
something four tenths of a point
it would have been the same inside
inside the computer as in in the source
code but instead I convert it to the
nearest binary fraction and therefore
strange anomalies occur which are very
confusing to the user it's too late to
change that so there's a mistake that I
learned from but I never was able to
Bank you know I never was able to
recover for him take back actually
there's a question on the web so the
question is if you were starting out as
a PhD student today what what area of
computer science do you think you
working if I were starting out of the
PhD student today what area of computer
science would I like to work in you know
I can just go down the down the halls
and and see that they all looked pretty
attractive but so I would choose the one
that that was closest to my own I'm to
my own skill set and I probably would
would be most attracted by by computer
graphics right right now because because
I really like using left brain and right
pane at the same time so I like I like
beautiful images as well as being able
to apply math to that something you'd
say cryptography what I was hoping you'd
say cryptography well
actually you're right but but I remember
something yeah in fact that's even but
because I remember the way you gave a
talk a couple years ago he said study
cryptography you have to really study
all of computer silent because because
everything has to be secure and so and
and so that doesn't so yeah you got it
you got no graphics to and that can't go
so that tops it why did I miss that
didn't say no no because you know I I
really want to learn about elliptic
curves and all that stuff I think it's
really cool ok do you think we will ever
create an actual artificial intelligence
one capable of self-awareness and able
to increase its own intelligence
exponentially singularity I think that
if that ever happens we we won't know it
today it is because there because it'll
be sort of Oh there'll be combination
between people and computers Oh to the
point where we're finally when the when
the people get left out of it it'll
almost be unnoticeable somehow but but I
don't really know I just I still think
that going for going towards that goal
has always been one of the most fruitful
sources of problems in computer science
and work and will continue as far as I
know but to me the big thing the biggest
unsolved um question in all of science
is the mystery of consciousness and even
though we're learning a lot more about
the way the the cortex work in the brain
and things like this I still feel that
seems to me the problem that to leave
please solve than anything I know so the
question that I had was we have lots of
these famous problems in computer
science such as P versus NP but what do
you think is the biggest bottleneck in
our understanding of the computational
Sciences to improving quality of life
with computer science
so now you're asking about quality of
life as opposed to quality of I mean the
question dad asked earlier was more like
just to stimulate the intellect but you
what you want to say well how do we
prove my life yeah I guess okay I don't
have a great answer but but but random
thoughts that come to my mind you know
this book that this book that I just
finished that worth flashing things on
this papers and fun and games like I got
I want to say word to about this I it's
the 8th volume out of 8 of the papers
that I've written throughout my career
and we saved this one to last because it
was the desert and and somehow I've
always enjoyed I mean I can't justify a
single chapter in this book by on
engineering grounds that it it was
necessary to write it but somehow I
couldn't not write these things like I
felt my life isn't complete unless I
written it so in some ways what when you
talk about quality of life you can say
well why do people build bridges and the
answer is so that they can cross the
river and have fun on the other side of
the river no there's so it's not so how
there's part of life has to do with with
the satisfaction of curiosity but also
you're it you're seeing beautiful
patterns and and and you know being able
to enjoy health but um but a lot of the
other things we do our that we consider
more practical are the means to be able
to have fun and games so okay so but I
don't understand why but this book when
I finished it I I felt overwhelming joy
that I was able to live
at a time in history when like when it
was possible to write a book like this
because that because it seemed to me
this was really somehow more connected
with my soul or what I at the basis of
what I do that if I hadn't been able to
do this kind of thing then my life would
have felt much less complete now but but
a lot of the questions might have been
in fact for me to say what's the of all
the things you know what's the what's
the top in some category rather and and
and this idea of rating things as saying
what's the best what's the most
interesting most important I never like
I never enjoyed that kind of that kind
of ranking because I well tell you
another story I I remember professor
Hart - your heart - coming to talk to me
in the middle 60s and he said he said to
me Don well what's the most important
result in computer science this year and
I couldn't think of anything but I mean
that was really stand out and I would
say you know oh yeah this is a great
breakthrough but I like this question so
night so every year after I asked myself
this question what was the greatest
thing happened in computer science this
year and I never come up with an answer
but after five years after ten years the
whole field has changed everything is
different and this the reason is it's
these small results the accumulation
thousands of people adding bricks to the
wall building built building this of
these structures that's what that's what
really matters or not and that sometimes
anything that gets on the top 10 list so
like I tend to look at that questions in
that in that way and and I think of
almost you know whatever people in this
room are doing is somehow contributing
the quality of life
for the for the whole it's probably with
repeating the name of the book it's
selected papers on fun and games but by
Duncan so there are some examples again
a left-brain right-brain some beautiful
patterns that come when you start
studying nights move on chessboard
okay now holding one so let's see
there's a very popular question here on
basically how tough mathematical
problems that you've solved and what is
generally your approach to solving these
hard problems okay so i i i worked on
lots of different problems over my life
and the hardest one that i ever better
that that i was ever able to resolve was
joint with with three other people
although I did like I think I did my
share it's called the birth of the giant
component in a random graph there's a
kite there's a big bang occurs if you
start out with with just a set of
vertices and then you at random choose
two vertices and join them and then and
do that over and over again and and you
ask how many things are joined together
all of a sudden a a dramatic change
happens when the number of connections
you've added is approximately 1/2 the
number versus 1/2 the number of vertices
that then then it goes from being almost
everybody isolated to having to having
components that are about the size of
this two-thirds power of the number of
vertices but then almost immediately
becomes linear and it goes through a
very fast phase transition a double
phase transition and by by using some
ideas of complex analysis that I that I
found really fun to explore it was
possible to slow this down and watch it
happen but by measuring time in a
different way and and we could see step
by step how these how
this explosion takes place and so that's
my that was my sort of greatest
mathematical discovery and and I enjoyed
doing it by just sort of always looking
around me whenever I never had a partial
result I I would I would learn the
territory as much as I can so when I go
into a problem I try to train my brain
the first week I'm doing baby steps and
and hopefully I can start doing giant
steps after a few weeks by by getting
familiar with a with a problem domain
problem area and and it helps to have a
rich problem like that one where there's
there were many many beautiful patterns
just wait just out there waiting to be
discovered I was a graduate student here
more than a decade ago
and I'm now a faculty at the albergue
educational institute which is a
university in India
professor new theorem ember as not only
as a great computer scientist but also
as as a great teacher
so my question now is is that over the
past several years the role of the
teacher is changing from that from that
of a traditional teacher to a
facilitator because almost all the
information that a teacher can probably
pass on to a student is already
available to this one because of the
information explosion so what are your
thoughts on that and then what would be
your advice for young elites I really
think it's always been that way that
just the information was there people
were getting as in different ways but
but it's not that different now as far
as that I mean I know that that we have
were more animated things now than we
did then and so on but still
to real knowledge sinks in about the
same same rate two persons praying as
ever and you guys in my classes while
I'm glad you said that I known as a good
teacher but I think I this you know at
Stanford we have really good students so
it's not a random sample I do try to be
a good writer and think a lot about it
exposition that way but in my classes at
Stanford I tried to concentrate on what
wasn't in the book and like what the
person said before recovering from
mistakes and so we would try to solve
problems as a group and then we would we
wouldn't get the answer right away but
then we would we would learn how to
rectify what we've done and so there
have been enough books for this this
kind yet and so that and and you know
also motivating students by when they
see that the professor flubs in some way
then they then then they get a little
bit of confidence in themselves so I
always tried to make a lot of mistakes
to well that's good to remember so a
related question here on the web what's
your what are your thoughts just related
information overload what are your
thoughts on open access journals as
opposed to subscription journals and
open access textbooks as opposed to paid
for textbooks all can be delivered over
the Internet right you see that playing
out right there's all of these things
open can it be downloaded this this
cannot be downloaded now it cost you 40
bucks ok 10% off in the home no right at
the beginning all right I like the I
like to have moderators quality control
and and the and and a lot of things can
be very well done by crowd-sourced and
and and done that way but I still
I'm such a nitpicker that I don't trust
anybody else to deal with my my eyes
doubting the eyes in my own book I don't
know
so my my approach right now has been to
to pay people like when they find
mistakes but but I am thinking about the
future and and making making ebooks out
of everything and and eventually making
it more accessible right now though the
quality control is they the open open
source journals I think are are really
natural because the the scientific
community for years has always been
doing all of the voluntary work for free
doing the refereeing and editorial
things and and that end of natural the
publishing in commercial journals Wow
when there was a lot of value added by
the commercial press they they could do
typesetting things that were really
difficult to do and they also they you
know they could copy editing now they do
very good printing and binding and they
and keeping subscription lists that's
all but that all takes a professional
work but I've compared to be speaking
there making some like 30 percent profit
you know I'm the shoulders of people who
did volunteer work to give the content
so it's not so most of the commercial
publishers except for professional
societies have started to I think be run
by businessmen rather than scientists so
so open access journals I've been a big
fan of that if people know that I that I
I felt guilty it because being the
editor of a journal that was whose
publisher had started to make
universities go broke by his reputation
policies and so I I
I looked up the facts and when the rest
of the editorial board looked at them
they agree with me and we resigned a
hundred percent and and went to another
went the ACM to to start a transactions
on algorithms um and this and there are
many other such cases still I am NOT a
total fan of this idea of of writing by
the whole community because I know
there's a lot of subtle things that that
might seem wrong and unless you really
understand them and so there's a really
terrific chance that that that democracy
will not work for for some of the lines
of code in tech for example what are
your perspectives on the increasingly
fracture state of academia and what
would you change if you had the power
including the what sorry improving the
what what sir what's your perspective on
the increasingly fractured state of
academia and would you change anything
if you had the power
fracture fractured space of academia oh
okay I'm sorry yeah I guess I better get
a hearing aids because the the my my
idea is that a few years from now people
will be identifying themselves with with
two areas instead of one everybody will
start thinking that their role in life
is to be an edge rather than a vertex a
serving has an interface between two
parts of academia so there will be
people who are you have to
subspecialties but that but that sort of
defines them as a link between those and
and they go only problem get getting the
areas to quality control because you
need enough to be able to tell someone
who who's really good at a good link
from from bad but anyway that's my
that's my my feeling uh the way things
will evolve this question concerns your
stint as the manager of the basketball
team at case this question concerns you
on stint as a manager of the basketball
team at Case Western and I saw video
audit which claimed that you use some
really good math to get good results for
your team could you briefly discuss that
and did it work okay so so if you look
in this book under basketball basketball
oh I got a little joking here about the
Celtx excuse me sir Celtics okay so 199
to 208 is where you want here and so so
here's the you know here's a picture
that came out the Cleveland papers at
the time this is me
this is this is the the datasheet that I
use when during the games to get
statistics and and here's my formula
okay this by the way I might have seen
the movie social networks where they had
a they had a couple of seconds where
they showed the algorithm in that then
and I had a chance to watch that movie
while I was on a plane to to England and
I could not and we had individual TV
sets like a freeze-frame and I could get
the algorithm and copy it down I think
this is a more interesting your
algorithm than the one but I still don't
believe the formula Louise it's a
question you you you look at problems
than you solve some and you analyze
father's and my question to you is what
what is your deep in your heart what do
you like more the solving of problems or
they analyze the analysis of them or how
to solo well ok so if i if I'm able to
solve it I like the fact that that I
usually like the math that went into the
solution because I gives me a give me a
rush when I see things cancelling out
and actually work and actually working
and see something go through like like
when I was working on this giant
component problem it's a similar thing
where where I could see that the that
the chance that a random graph the
largest component always it's the only
one that has that has well it's a
technical term but more than one cycle
always always stays the chance that
there's only one such component
throughout the whole evolution of the
what turned out to be something like PI
squared over 12 I don't know there was
some 7 7 12 spy squared I don't remember
the exact number but anyway the getting
that the mathematics was the beauty
there to see to see the number and it's
similar when I was I mean to me the the
intellectual excitement of of knowing
how to solve a whole lot of problems is
more important than solving any one
particular problem but I I i wrote a
simulation what language once that that
made it easy for people to to to figure
out how well certain of queueing
mechanisms would work or we had
different different computers hooked
together and other kinds of units and
and how much delay there would be and so
on
but I I always felt that there that it
was more important more fun to set up
the model of these systems than actually
to run them and get the answer in fact
that I regretted putting up with
statements in this language
I thought that the learning occurred
while you were describing the model so I
have this these strange ideas that that
the that the journey is more important
than the destination most the time I
like I look for I look around to smell
the roses and working on problems I
think something like 35 or more years
ago I remember you saying that computer
science didn't have enough deep results
to qualify as a real science and I
question is are we there yet
yes yeah but but actually I am I guess I
didn't put it in okay
in in the art of computer programming I
I added a new appendix
to match the one that's in this one
there's index two algorithms or theorems
in vying for a and then I put I put a
similar index in in the first three
volumes but in each case I have another
quotation at the bottom of the page and
and I quoted that particular statement
in in one of those three volumes and but
that that work that was something I said
as you say long long ago and and a
friend of mine had said like he's
willing to believe that computer science
is a field as soon as it has a thousand
deep theorems and I said no no five
hundred deep theorems and five hundred
deep algorithms but but that but uh but
you know as soon as we reach that level
then we'll certainly justify our
presence on campus and I think we and I
think we passed that 20 years ago easily
so and if it weren't true I would have
been done with these books long long ago
so we're actually at the top of the hour
but there's one maybe last question yeah
okay that's everybody on the web seems
to I want to know the answer to okay so
when you write your programs what
programming language do you alright so I
use C web and here's here's an example
in the in this book I have a an
extensive example of a literate program
for the game of adventure the the the
the the thing that sort of started
computer gaming in the first place by
the way also have a really cool map of
the caves in here which I think is
better than
I can check that off anyway but that
this but but will Crowther and Don words
like came up with this game adventure in
the 70s and and it was one of the
reasons why computers were used in the
70s I I mean that in the game of life
were two things that you that everybody
was doing but then when their boss came
by they would they would hide it and and
John McCarthy four-bed people from you
from playing this game during 39 during
working hours and so on but it bring
it's addictive and full of full of a
great beautiful ideas so I wanted to
capture that in in c-webb language which
is my favorite language for writing
programs like I wrote I write about five
programs a week and see where most of
them are pretty short but sometimes it
takes me you know quite a few lines of
code and I and I'm gonna be next month
I'm gonna be or I guess kick July
because I'm gonna be away next month I'm
gonna try to write a really good Sat
solver in NC Webb in July so so it's and
I got another book called the Stanford
graph base that consists of 3035
examples of see web programs each of
each of which you know eight pages long
or so that that solving to have
interesting algorithms applied to graph
theory and if if and I enjoyed much
writing those programs I had Stanford
undergrads
helping me and and to me as I said half
an hour ago or an hour ago it's the
greatest invention since sliced bread
but I I can't be unbiased and since I I
came up with it but it was to me it's
the most important spin-off of my work
on tech because
because I developed that style of
programming in order to write tech and
marathon great ok top of the hour so
dawn is gonna be is gonna be out for a
few more minutes I don't know just
outside the room oh maybe I'm gonna sit
here oh we can that's that's fine
refreshments are outside yes thank you
yes all right so I'd like to think on
[Applause]